Catherine gum
what were you employed to do I
translated signals intelligence and have
I reported anything to interest to my
clients you're a spy
[Music]
did you capacity pal the Americans want
us to help them get a UN resolution for
war so you work for the British
government no I work for the British
people
I do not gather intelligence so that the
government can lie to the British people
intelligence may be being manipulated to
take this country to war I could get
your copy
you're asking me to put it in a breach
of the Official Secrets Act phone call
that treason someone has betrayed their
government and their country
you might need our help if we you do not
go public we would be conceding that no
one can ever tell the people when their
government is lying your marriage will
be interrogated my husband had
absolutely nothing to do with this he's
a Muslim I'm sorry
[Music]
you chose loyalty to your country over
loyalty to your government your marriage
and yourself I think that speaks rather
highly of you Catherine Louise a gun you
charged with an offense at the Official
Secrets Act do you want to risk it all
how do you plead
[Music]
you